before getting into a negotiation it's
very important to set a floor and a
ceiling so you know where to move right
because if you don't you can be
manipulated and you can you know lose
yourself in the emotions because if
you're a good negotiator you will
obviously try at least to be completely
disconnected emotionally from the deal
and negotiation itself although you will
play emotional so if you are not upset
you can play upset but none of that
matters unless you don't unless you
don't have a floor and a ceiling so you
need to know if you go under the floor
you need to walk out or you know end the
negotiation and at the ceiling you need
to know to accept so you can close the
deal time is very interesting when it
comes to negotiation I always say in
real estate time kills everything all
deals that bit of time a few seconds
minutes or sometimes a couple hours
depending on the situation which you can
use and delay to get where you want
because people get frustrated to a
certain point and in a good way if you
don't give the information right away
just hold it back tiny tiny bits and
make them wait that could be good as an
example when I go into an apartment and
the seller is there always asking me at
the end of the appointment cell Fredrik
what is my penthouse worth I never ever
give a price in the apartment one
because I want to do my research and
really go home and think about it and I
don't want to be drawn into any
excitement which I could potentially be
because it's so beautiful but it's also
the purpose of this discussion having
them wait three and a half hours for an
email to come with the price will make
them want it more and then having it
come in writing will feel more
substantial and real because it's coming
in an email you had to wait for it
you